bonjour fraises leur dis donc bonjour
mon idole temps merci de m'avoir invité
bonjour à toutes les martiniquaises et à
tous les martiniquais vice président m'a
servi de martinique le mois de juin une
prochaine plénière des élus prévue les
20 et 21 juin dans dix jours donc l'une
des dernière avant les vacances pour les
élus en cette fin de saison avez-vous
l'impression le sens que le travail a
été fait malgré une ambiance parfois un
peu tendu dans l'hémicycle l'assemblée
fonctionne c'est la démocratie il y à
une majorité qui est plutôt malade qui
est un chien divisé pas très efficace
dans la mise en oeuvre des politiques
selon vino et puis nos positions qui
fait son boulot qui fait des
propositions c'est que modestement ce
que je tente de faire on s'attaquera au
budget de la collectivité lors de cette
prochaine plénière on va pas tirer de
plans sur la comète mais les questions
sur les comptes de l'assemblée ce sont
des chiffres qui doivent traduire qui
peuvent traduire une ambition de la
collectivité
on ne parlera pas budget alloué un
budget supplémentaire messieurs de
comptes administratifs les résultats de
l'année 2018 qui sont présentés en
déficit d'un million d'euros alors qu'en
réalité ils sont excédentaires de plus
de 23 millions d'euros puisque
martinique transport un matelas qui
n'est pas utilisé mais il y a aussi un
certain nombre de dépenses qui ne sont
pas tout à fait clair puisqu'on nous dit
qu'il y aurait 35 millions d'euros de
dépenses faites pour lesquels il n'y a
pas de mandat donc aujourd'hui je le
répète le pays est à l'arrêt c'est le
sentiment des martiniquais et ce ne sont
pas les quelques aujourd'hui manoeuvre
budgétaires qui sont fait qu'ils vont
changer cette opinion la réalité c'est
qu'il faut changer de braquet et je
dirais changer de politique
et pourquoi pas changer de conseiller
exécutif pour vous les chiffres ce sera
tout sauf au drapeau colo que l'on
pourrait icéo écouter cette affaire de
drapeaux et la jouissance de chiffres
hélas hélas cette affaire de drapeaux a
pris le pas sur les utilisations de
chiffres de finances on en revient on en
revient on en revient - sol tant sur la
faible utilisation des fonds européens
hélas il y à une catastrophe qui
s'annonce
parce qu'on nous fait croire qu'il y a
beaucoup de dépenses programmées mais je
prendrai
l'exemple les fonds pour la pêche le
fonds européen pour les affaires
maritimes et la pêche
à peine 25 % des crédits ont été
mobilisés alors que l'on sait que les
martiniquais veulent manger du poisson
local et qu'il faut accompagner les
pêcheurs menti qui viennent
d'obtenir une dérogation de l'union
européenne pour avoir des embarcations
plus performante et surtout pour
financer les dispositifs de
concentration de poissons alors souvent
la nounou journalistes ne se sont
montrés du doigt par surtout par
certains internautes peut-être des
aficionados de tel ou tel élu c'est que
cette question des fonds européens
la gestion des fonds européens font
jérémy a été l'objet de querelles très
vite votre personnalité plutôt forte au
sein de l'hémicycle
c'est un simple quand c'est un vrai faux
sujets où c'est de la pure politique
politicienne
écoutez j'espère que ça va pas se
terminer devant les tribunaux le premier
vice président de l'assemblée yan
monplaisir et devant les tribunaux face
au président du conseil exécutif ya 737
millions je ne vous savez aussi que le
président du groupe majorité a le
collègue gunilla et devant les tribunaux
avec le président du mime pour la
dévolution de l'actif du mime qui se
fait dépecer
alors j'espère bien qui aura pas là un
conflit juridique entre le collègue
l'aventuré et puis la collègue line et
orbi ce que l'on constate voici un
exemple précis 28 millions d'euros qui
doivent servir au financement des
entreprises martiniquaises et 28
millions d'euros qui ne sont pas
utilisés et il y à un cancan et j'ai
demandé en plénière au président du
conseil exécutif en sa qualité de
président d'arbitré et de m
c'est déjà mise aux voix mais de mettre
en oeuvre un projet qui a été votée je
le rappelle en jeux 2018 à l'unanimité
c'est un vrai sujet politique ou bien
tout simplement du cocan pour faire du
buzz la part des élus relayée par les
médias
écoutez dans une collectivité où vous
avez une forme
je n'ose pas le mot mais une forme de
vacance du pouvoir
aujourd'hui le conseil exécutif qu'est
ce qu'il fait il nous met devant le fait
accompli mais ils refusent de nous
donner l'eau dit 2017
il refuse de nous communiquer nos
oppositions mais même à sa majorité
l'organigramme de la collectivité il
refuse de n'être que 10 g de la
collectivité
on n'a pas hélas il refuse de mettre à
la disposition des martiniquais la liste
des entreprises attendait moins 8 ans
qui bénéficient des fonds européens
cette nuit je les demande et elle est de
droit on doit nous dire en martinique
quelles sont les entreprises qui
bénéficient des fonds européens se créa
et pourtant on n'a pas ces documents
donc aujourd'hui la difficulté c'est que
vous avez une majorité divisée
un personnel lui qui se sent abandonnée
et qui est démotivé et puis il ya le
fait de tous ces cancans qui n'arrête
pas et qui inquiète les martiniquais il
est venu le temps d'investir aujourd'hui
dans les transports et de faire que les
fonds européens soient convenablement
utilisé par rôle d'opposant écoutez
proposition d'opposants il ya 28
millions d'euros la façon vous trouvez
normal qu'on donne 2 millions d'euros de
pénalités au groupe vinci aux banques
quand vous avez des transporteurs qui
voient leur entreprise disparaître il
fallait prendre ces 24 millions d'euros
d'excédent financer l'acquisition des
bus pour les transporteurs martiniquais
et nous à convergence progressis nous
proposons qu'il y ait des bus au rsca
convergence prog et heath matinée kpn
ouais c'est le nom d'un mouvement qui a
été lancé il ya quelques temps par vos
hobbies par nouve lle par quelques amis
plusieurs
j'ai vu une fille frêle renouvelé le
sifel renouvelle l'offre politique dans
ma dignité et et vous verrez dans les
essayer vous avez vu le sort des
républicains vous avez vu le sort du
parti socialiste français et vous avez
vu le sort du mime et vous voulez qu'on
craint nouveau parti on va aujourd'hui
apporter un nouveau parti à la nébuleuse
indépendantistes comme je vois non
aujourd'hui il faut qu aujourd'hui
les fouilles ont déjà le cri aujourd'hui
il faut il faut rassembler les
martiniquais autour d'un projet et
convergence progressiste matinik va
faire en sorte qu'il y ait un projet
veut rassembler où sont rassemblés les
martiniquaises et les martiniquais
nous revenons sur cette histoire de
drapeaux n'êtes vous pas fier en tant
que élu en tant que martiniquais en tant
que membre d'une collectivité de voir et
bien ce fanion venir et représenter la
martinique à l'international n'ont
d'ailleurs en plénière j'ai affiché très
clairement mon opinion j'ai montré le
drapeau tricolore de la république
française de côté de l'autre le drapeau
gouvernance au milieu pour cacher la
possible
comment il ya de la place au milieu pour
mettre ce troisième drapeau oui pour
mettre le drapeau de l'union européenne
à la bannière étoilée pour ajouter ce
drap tôt ce n'est pas moi qui le rejette
son unité avec le rapport a été adopté
je le répète dans des conditions opaques
sans transparence en consultation de
l'assemblée combien de gens ont voté ou
et où sont les résultats du vote et sky
ont eu ici on ne sait rien et puis on
voit brusquement un drapeau qui est mis
devant l'hôtel de la cité elle qui fait
l'unité bonhomme de chemin avec eux
il est au siège de l'eau c'est ce que je
les ai vus alors là il ya une petite
anecdote assez cocasse c'est peut-être
l'occasion pour moi de
je ne fais pas souvent de recadrer un
agent de la collectivité qui a eu un
certain nombre de commentaires sur ma
prise de position puisque vous le savez
avec des citoyens martiniquais nous
avons décidé de faire un recours
gracieux auprès de monsieur le président
du conseil exécutif et j'ai entendu sur
une radio locale concurrentes une un
agent qui se prétend fille de et qui
mettait appel en tant que vice président
de l'assemblée de martinique sur cette
question de drapeaux alors je serais
tenté de lui dire comme si je parlais à
ma fille arrête tes bêtises tu es un
agent de la collectivité
on te demande de faire fonctionner
l'administration ne te mêle pas de
politique ou bien mais trois sur une
liste vous adresser à fi de la fille
d'un précis pour ceux qui n'auraient pas
compris
écoutez chacun d'interpréter mais chacun
va être amené des jeunes le jeudi
un homme politique va pas faire ça tout
est bon le sujet majeur toul et
martinique
j'ai fermé la parenthèse j'ai relu fait
à 7 2 6 2 va comprendre qu'ici elle veut
faire de la politique il faut qu'elle se
remette sur une liste mais que je suis
élu de cette collectivité vice président
de l'assemblée représentant 61 du mil
martiniquais je ne permettrai à aucun
agent de la collectivité territoriale de
martinique de me prendre à parti
politiquement sur une radio il faut que
ces filles alors on peut parler d'eux si
vous voulez du service des incendies et
goûter voici là quelque chose qui
intéresse des martys il faut cliquer sur
le répondeur je vous donne des sujets
qui sont qui intéresse véritablement les
manteaux en peau de vous embaucher moins
nantis nick première c'est ça on voulait
pas descendre
l'orne par exemple du comité des oeuvres
sociales
ah oui par exemple voilà un sujet là
dessus j'ai pu passer complètement
inaperçue lors de la dernière plénière
la gestion du comité des oeuvres
sociales c'est un dossier il était
question de fusionner le cos issue
l'ecosse issus de la région et du
département
finalement tout cela l'idée est émise
que cela soit confiée à l'ile-de-france
dossiers suspendus pour l'heure pourquoi
parce que là l'assemblée et je voulais
saluer l'initiative
en tout cas le discours du président lee
qui a été très ferme et qui a parlé de
régression l'action sociale en
martinique pour les personnels
territoriaux doit être localisée à
nantes inique et dans la caille
il n'est pas question dans mon point de
vue et de celui de la majorité de
l'assemblée que l'action sociale soit
déporté délocaliser en ile de france
auprès du centre national d'action
sociale
si nous voulons construire des oeuvres
sociales dans la caraïbe à partir de la
martinique
il faut que la décision de domicilier
les eaux social en martinique mais c'est
un vrai atout si les chiffres de l'est
plusieurs alliances au cos ce comité des
états serait pas clair si des décisions
prises par les tribunaux il y à des
instances qui ont été élus ces instances
maintenant sont clairement désigné elles
ont compétence il faut travailler avec
elle vous pouvez comprendre qu'à frais
de marie-jeanne puisse se dire tout
simplement 6
à comprendre ça doit quitter sa nou camp
à l'autre côté du pays
cela s'appelle une attitude autocratique
ouais aujourd'hui l'assemblée et claude
lise et là il y à un large consensus de
tous les élus sur cette question nous
devons non pas au nom des questions
d'économie parce que c'est ce que j'ai
entendu dire que ça va coûter 800 mille
euros si on délocalise en île de france
par rapport à une localisation en
martinique où ça va coûter 2 millions
d'euros les personnels
le néo international de la collectivité
territoriale de matinée les personnels
oui lorsqu'on tient à mylan et vous me
donnez l'occasion de donner un chiffre
100 millions d'euros sur le compte de la
ctm au trésor fin 2017 environ 70
millions d'euros sur le compte au trésor
fin 2018 c'est peut-être leur taux de la
stratégie dite lambie simat la dernière
question parce qu'il resterait très peu
de temps ces fameux travaux de photos
commandées début février pour aller pour
les regarder pour les europe
des photos ou concernant l'assemblée
générale de pays acp
c'est un cancan c'est un vrai faux
sujets politiques aussi de la politique
politicienne
c'est surtout sordide il est
inacceptable que des fonds publics
puissent être utilisés pour aller
photographier un mouvement concurrent
d'ailleurs j'ai demandé que les photos
soient projetés à l'assemblée plénière
il ne les a pas reçus j'espère qu'elles
seront projetés et qu'elle sera envoyée
à la presse
et aussi au monde de l'assemblée qui
vont se rendre en vos chances dans cette
aile lüthi ou pas qu'est ce qui vous ce
qui me choque c'est qu'on utilise 1400
euros de fonds publics pour quelque
chose qu'il n'a rien d'éthéré public il
y a tout simplement une querelle
politicienne entre deux mouvements
indépendantistes à la ctm
il faut arrêter tout cela c'est votre
opinion merci - wolton merci d'avoir été
avec tout ce matin frais de l'ordi nous
rappelle que vous êtes vice président de
l'assemblée de martinique et compte se
donnent rendez vous les 20 et 21 juin
prochains pour la prochaine plénière des
élus de la 7e journée bonne journée à
tous
[Musique]